Ho scritto una canzone su un temporale e uh,
sta piovendo oggi e ho pensato
che fosse una canzone perfetta cosa
fa un americano in Italia e
tutti gli italiani mi chiedono se posso,
per favore, pensare di camminare
bene Tim Castamere
uh
un sacco di poliziotti che lo sanno  le tempeste
puliscono molto bene e portano anche alcuni buoni
cambiamenti quindi un
uragano di cambiamento e se sei
ispirato puoi provare a cantare su
alcuni dei Corpses
[Musica]
sembra che dovrei fare qualcosa da
lasciare andare
perché non lo fai anche tu  dì qualcosa
che non so Mi
sento come una casa morta sul tuo
muro
Sono un albero alto, tesoro, come mai mi sento così
piccola Amanda [
Musica]
nessuno
cambia il calcio
[Musica]
grazie
ogni volta che dici di no io  sento così freddo
[Musica]
come puoi essere così vicino e io sono così solo
romperò il silenzio
oh non sopporto la sua Pietra
[Musica]
In alto sopra la montagna tra noi adesso
Rock Your Boat
[Musica]
nessuno
ho visto il treno,
sì,
uragano
[Musica]
sventoli la tua bandiera bianca e apri la
porta,
sto salendo, nessuno vince il mondo,
pensavo che fossimo invincibili,
ora mi sento invisibile,
è un altro atto di Dio,
sono usa e getta
[Musica]
[Applausi]
il treno
poi i fari
[Musica]
vuole cambiare
come
[Musica]
un uragano
una possibilità
[Musica]
grazie
[Applausi]